[MUSIC PLAYING]
IAN LAKE: Hi, everyone.
My name is Ian lake.
DANIEL SANTIAGO RIVERA:
Hi, I'm Daniel Santiago.
BEN WEISS: And I'm Ben Weiss.
IAN LAKE: We're here to talk
about a little thing called
navigation.
What is navigation?
If you're here for Google Maps,
you're not in the right talk
because today we'll be talking
specifically about the Jetpack
NAVIGATION component.
Now when we say component,
what does that actually mean?
Well, let's look at what the
mission statement for Jetpack
Navigation actually is.
It's a suite of libraries,
tooling, and guidance
that provide a robust
navigation framework
for in-app navigation.
So a very specific goal is kind
of that in-app navigation--
that navigation
between screens--
and provide more than
just the libraries,
but also tooling and guidance
to go along with that.
I think it's best to explain
navigation with a sample app.
Here, we're going to
build a trivia app.
Because I'm a Googler, it
of course has chat built in.
We have a chat list that has
all of your conversations.
Then, of course, a chat fragment
which will actually have
the actual conversation itself.
And of course, a profile.
All these will be available
via a navigation drawer
on our main activity.
We chose fragments
here because they
provide a really
good integration
with other architecture
components, like view models
and lifecycle.
To kind of actually
make this all work,
we're putting all of these
fragments in a NavHostFragment.
This is the thing that
navigation provides
for you, which is basically
the container where
as we swap between these
different screens in our app,
the NavHostFragment is
what's actually going to be
that container in your layout.
What do we actually need to
build out this sample app?
Its a 40 minute talk.
We're going to go fast.
We have a navigation
graph, itself.
This is the map of
your app, and it
has four fragment
destinations-- our four screens.
Then of course, we're going
to have a menu, and that'll
be for setting up our side
navigation-- our navigation
view, with what items
we want in that list.
Then we have our layout
for our activity, which
is going to have a drawer
layout for our side nav,
a toolbar for our top app bar,
and then our NavHost fragment,
which is actually going to be
the main content of our app.
And then lastly, we just need
an activity to kind of tie
all those things together.
What does this
actually look like?
First, we'll start
with the graph.
We wanted deep integration
in the tooling.
So in Android Studio--
3.4 and 3.5-- we have
a navigation editor.
So besides being able
to do things in xml,
and also programmatically
if you're up for that,
you'll also get a visual
editor where we can actually
see the structure of our whole
app here with all the pieces,
and all the links
between each one.
For example, between the
chat list and the chat.
Next, for our menu.
It's all very kind
of basic stuff--
IDs, icons, and
titles for each one.
But the important
part here is we'll
use the same IDs as we put
in our navigation graph.
This is what will let navigation
tie these things together
automatically.
Now of course, for
our actual layout.
We've stripped out a few
layout widths and heights,
so don't try and compile this.
But that's all the
important bits.
Specifically, has
one important bit,
which is the actual
NavHost fragment itself.
Here, we'll just put it
directly in our layout--
NavHost fragment-- and
here's where we'll actually
use that AppNav graph
to tie that to the graph
that we created in our xml.
Then to look up our navigation
view for that side nav,
we'll just attach the same
menu that we built here.
Now what we really need
is just the activity
that binds all these
things together.
We've made it really easy from
anywhere in your activity,
as well as anywhere
in a fragment, as well
as any view within
that whole hierarchy
to get an instance of
your NavController.
So, call an extension
for findNavController
with just the ID of
your NavHost fragment.
Of course, if you're using
the Java programming language,
then you'll be able
to use a static method
to do the exact same thing.
Once we have this
NavController--
this thing that is powering
all of navigation--
what do we actually do with it?
We can do a couple of things.
One, we can set up our
toolbar at the top.
What we'll do here is
use appBarConfiguration.
This is kind of
that figuring out
what that top app
bar is supposed
to do in the first place.
And the first thing we want
to do is make sure that all
of those top level
destinations--
those three things in
our navigation view--
are all kind of at the
same visual hierarchy.
We pass on the list here,
and those are the ones
that won't show an up arrow.
They're all at the same
visual hierarchy level.
We want to make sure we tell
navigation oh, these three
destinations are important.
Then, we're going to pass in
the actual drawer layout itself.
This is the key that
says when you're
on one of those top
level destinations,
instead of showing
no icon at all,
you want to show
that hamburger icon
so that users know that they
can pull out the drawer.
And then, with that
appBarConfiguration setup,
all we call is
.setupWithNavController,
another Kotlin extension
on the toolbar here.
Now, as we navigate
between screens of our app,
we're automatically updating
the title in the toolbar.
We're automatically
changing the icon,
and there's nothing
else we need to do
to hook up to get the
correct up behavior,
to get the correct label.
It's all kind of built
into this functionality,
because we've set up our
appBarConfiguration correctly.
Similarly, for our
navigation view,
it's the same type of thing.
We have just another
setup with NavController.
Now, whenever you click on
something in your side nav,
it's automatically going
to go to the right screen,
because we used that
same ID in the menu,
and at the navigation graph.
Similarly, the
selected item is always
going to stay in-sync with
where you're at in the graph.
Now we don't need to
focus on anything else.
But we built a lot of things.
We never need to touch
our activity again.
But how do we actually
put this all together?
Well, it started with
the common library,
and this is where
they actually have
the runtime equivalent
of navigation graphs
and all of the kind
of base components.
On top of that is the actual
navigation runtime library.
This is kind of that
thing that provides
the actual NavController itself.
But on top of that,
we realized, OK.
That's kind of the
core pieces, but we
want to build a few things.
A lot of people
do use fragments.
They are probably one of
the most popular APIs--
not from a popularity, but
from a usage perspective.
We wanted something
out of the box,
and especially that integration
with other architecture
components was really important.
We have the NavHost
fragment, and the ability
to use fragment destinations in
a navigation fragment library.
Similarly, if you're using
those material components
like toolbars, and
other things, then we
have a navigation UI, which
is what provides the app bar
configuration, and all these
setup with NavController items.
These top two items
are totally optional.
If you want to go off the
rails and do something totally
different, we do
support all of that
as well, just using
navigation runtime.
And of course,
because it's 2019,
we have ktx versions
of all of these.
Kotlin extensions for
all of these things
as well as a Kotlin DSL for
building navigation graphs,
and many other features
if you're using Kotlin.
We talked a little bit
about the library side,
and saw the navigation editor,
but we also have more tooling
integration as well.
So being able to integrate
in with manifest merger,
so you don't have to write
intent filters for deep links.
We can build that for
you out of the deep links
you put in your
navigation graph.
Similarly, we also have a Safe
Args Gradle plugin, which we'll
talk about more in detail.
That really makes it easy
to move between destinations
in a type-safe way.
And of course, we also talked
about the guidance side
of things.
One of the things that was
really important for us
is to not just throw a
library over the wall,
but instead really talk to
our internal design teams,
and other teams
outside of Google,
say, what actually
works for developers?
How can we make a consistent
experience across everyone?
And that really came up
with a lot of the guidance,
and a lot of the
documentation that we provide.
We have quite a few pages
on developer.android.com
that really go into
the details on not only
how to use navigation,
but also some of the why,
and some the reasonings
behind things,
and the ways to really
kind of set it up
in a consistent way
across every app.
Also, we have worked with
DevRel and other organizations
to make sure that
you have good getting
started points
with our Code Lab.
The documentation was
a really big focus
for the navigation stable
release last month,
but it also is a big focus for
our Navigation 2.1 release,
which is in alpha right now.
One of the things in there
was dialogue destinations.
In addition to using
full screen fragments,
now you can use a
dialogue destination
and then you can
navigate to a dialogue.
It's supported out of the
box by NavHost fragment,
just like fragment
destinations, and allows
you to use all the same
actions and arguments
as you would for any
other kind of destination.
What does this
look like in code?
Instead of just using the
fragment tag for a fragment,
now we can use a dialog
tag for a dialog.
That's pretty easy, right?
Same type of things
are supported.
If you have arguments--
for example here,
we have an error message for
our error dialog fragment.
Those all still work, just
like any other destination.
Another feature
that we were really
excited about for
Navigation 2.1 was
integration with ViewModels.
ViewModels are an architecture
component about saving data
across configuration changes.
With the new safe
state ViewModels,
even saving things across
process death and recreation.
But we realized
there was something
that needed to happen in
between the activities
scope, i.e. the entire
app, as well as just
the individual fragment level.
Now you can actually scope
things to a navigation graph.
Let's take a look at
what that looks like.
Here's our four
destinations that we had.
Now we want to add
an on-boarding flow.
Our on-boarding flow is welcome,
setup, and find friends,
because of course, we got to
connect to all of our friends
with a totally incompatible
proprietary API.
But for these things,
we want to share
data between these fragments.
So by encapsulating this
in an on-boarding graph--
a nested graph--
we actually have
a way of attaching information
at the graph level,
rather than just at
the destination level.
What does this look like?
We can just use a by
navViewModels Kotlin property
delegate to actually
get an instance
of our on-boarding
ViewModel from any one
of the destinations
within that graph.
Now of course, there's a static
method for Java users, as well.
So it totally works on both.
Then, we can do
whatever we want.
In this case, when
setup is complete,
we save the user ID
into our ViewModel.
That allows our next
fragment to then
get an instance of that
exact same ViewModel,
even if you've
done configuration
changes across things, and then
extract that information out
of it.
Or maybe you do
something more useful,
because this is a toy
example for slides.
These are all kind of based
on a lot of what we built
for navigation stables release.
One of the things I was most
excited for was Safe Args.
And to talk more about
Safe Args, here's Danny.
DANIEL SANTIAGO
RIVERA: Thanks, Ian.
[APPLAUSE]
Like Ian mentioned, Safe
Args is a gradle plugin
that basically complements
the navigation library.
It basically graphs
your navigation file,
analyzes them, and
generates some code for you
to use your
application to help you
safely pass arguments, and
navigate to valid destinations.
Now you might be wondering,
why did we create a Safe Args,
or why would you
even use Safe Args?
After all, it's an
optional plugin,
but we highly recommend
that you use it.
The main reason is that
some of the checks that
are performed at runtime now
get to be done at compile time.
So this means you get to do
factorization as you work
with your navigation graph.
Because it generates
code, it means
it can leverage some
of the assistant tools
in Android Studio, for example.
Autocomplete will kick in
when you're trying to use it.
And again, because
it generates code,
it means it transforms your
types in your navigation
argument to actual types
in the language system.
Let's take a look at it, and how
to use it and the kind of code
it generates.
We're back to the
shop application.
We've got our new requirement.
Our bosses-- as usual--
give us more work.
This time, when we
click on the thumbnail
on one of the chat lists,
we get to go to a profile.
So now we have two
destinations that we
can get from our chat list.
If we take a look at how we
have defined our chat list
destination, as usual,
you define the fragment
that it uses, and the two
arrows that come out of it
are the two actions
that we have,
and these are the two
destinations that you
would use to get out of it.
Now we are on our
chat list frontman.
We're trying to hook
things together.
We're implementing
our profile image.
Click listener, we
have a NavController.
And usually, you would
navigate using your action.
This is how you would do a
normal navigation usually,
without Safe Args.
But with Safe Args, instead you
will use the generated code.
You would use this class called,
ChatListFragmentDirections.
We'll see it in a bit.
But the cool thing here is
as you're trying to use it,
the ID kicks in,
and you actually
have autocomplete on
the ballot actions
that you can take
from this destination.
Now what does Safe
Args actually generate?
For each destination, it'll
generate a directions class,
and this class basically has
functions for the value actions
that you can take.
These functions also
actually have parameters,
and these parameters are
based on the arguments
that you have in your action.
And if they have
default values, they
will show it here as default
value, as you can see.
This is how we make sure that
by calling this function,
and passing the
right parameters,
you will be able to receive them
on the other side correctly.
Safe Args also
generates a second set
of classes which we
call, the Args classes.
We navigate it now to
the profile frontmen,
and we want to
parse the arguments.
We will use what we call,
the profile frontmen
args, and generate a
class by the Safe Args.
And this is just
a beta class that
contains your actual
types of your arguments.
But as you can see, it has
these two methods-- tobundle,
frombundle.
You would use these methods
to actually get the Args out.
But using this method
is how we basically
take the responsibility
from you from using bundles.
Even better, if
you're using Kotlin,
we also have this
extension legacy function
by Nav Args, which
helps you get those Args
and start assessing that
data pretty quickly.
Now you might have noticed
that the generated code is
in Kotlin, and that's because
Safe Args will actually
generate both Java
and Kotlin code.
Some people were pretty
excited about it.
They stopped pressing
the shift button.
Now if we use the plugin, you
just go to your build a gradle,
apply the plugin with the ID.
Using this ID will
generate the Java code,
but using the Kotlin
version of the ID
will generate the Kotlin code.
Pretty straightforward.
Why did we decide
to generate Kotlin?
There's two main benefits.
One is [INAUDIBLE] performance.
If you have a
Kotlin-only app, then
generate the Kotlin
code, that means you
don't have [INAUDIBLE] sources.
And the second is that we get
to use idiomatic Kotlin code.
In the Java version
of the generator code,
we have builders.
But in the Kotlin version,
we have data classes
with primary constructor that
you can use name arguments
and default arguments.
So that's pretty nice,
because their data classes,
you also have things like
copy, hashcode, and those kinds
of things for your arguments.
Now whether the plugin
generates Kotlin or Java code,
it doesn't mean a lot if we
don't support a lot of types.
So we started out supporting
the [INAUDIBLE] type,
and as we got
closer to stable, we
were able to add support for
parcelable, serializable,
and enum.
So if you have actions
that have arguments
that are parcelable
and enums, you
can use those with
the new documentation.
We actually have a pretty table
with all of this information.
You can look up there
how the syntax looks,
whether it supports a file,
default values or not,
nullable and things like that.
[INAUDIBLE] is pretty
good when you're
trying to work with a
tightly coupled graph,
but sometimes you might need
to have a more deep couple
navigation graph.
And Ben here will talk to you
a little bit more about that.
BEN WEISS: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
Modularizing applications has
become increasingly important,
especially since last year,
we announced the Android app
bundle.
And this year, with
dynamic feature modules
being generally
available, we will
see a lot more applications
that will be modularized.
This not only reflects to your
application while you develop
it, but it allows you-- with
dynamic feature modules--
to actually ship parts of your
application to your users.
A couple of the benefits
that are on modularization
during development are that you
can cut down your build times
by creating distinct modules.
Also, you can separate
the concerns within those.
Separation of concerns
also is around navigation.
Navigation library
supports modularization.
Let's talk a little bit
about how you can split up
your graph while you
break up your application
into distinct modules.
We saw this graph grow
over this presentation,
and we have a couple of-- if
you look at the Design Editor
here--
we have a home graph, which
also has the arrow dialog.
We have a chat list,
we have the chat,
and we have the
profile, as well.
Also, we have a
nested graph in here.
We can break this
up in multiple ways.
What we are doing here
is we are breaking up
this graph into several
distinct libraries.
We will still continue to
have one application module.
We will have a home module,
a chat, and a profile.
We'll just take that away, and
put it into a distinct graph,
in a distinct library
module, as well.
If you take a look at
this navigation file,
it's really, really tricky
to see what's going on here.
This is already a very
simplified example,
if you have a real world app
you can keep on scrolling
with these for a long time.
So what we do instead is we just
break it up into the modules.
We take out the
relevant destinations,
and put those into
the files where
they are going to be used.
We do that for each of the
modules that we are creating.
As you can see, each of
that has a start destination
that we're able to jump into.
Then, we include
these in the graph
that we are hosting in
the application itself.
All the modules
that we have created
can be included in that.
The way this works
is, using the include
tag that has been around
since we launched navigation.
You simply include the graph
that we have started out here.
This goes alongside each
other navigation destination
that already exists.
You can have nested graphs, or
any other destination in here.
This is really cool when
you have independent graphs,
and you want to
navigate between those.
That's great.
But what if you want to move
from one graph to another?
Our chat app has grown.
We have a profile
fragment, but also we
want to have friends in the app.
We want to make sure that we
have the friend list there,
as well.
And since you can navigate from
the profile to the friend list,
we have that in
the profile graph.
So what you can do
here with ID, is
you can simply reference
the chat graph and the start
destination here.
But that will only
lead us so far.
Actually, what we would like to
have is we want to go straight.
If we click on the friend
list, what we want to do
is we want to go straight
to the chat fragment,
and being able to chat
directly with a friend,
rather than going
to the chat list
first, and then
jumping in there.
With IDs-- like I
said-- it's not only
possible to jump directly to the
start destination of the graph.
That's why with Navigation
2.1 we have enabled navigation
by URIs so you can use deep
links to navigate directly
to destinations, even
across graph boundaries.
How this works is
you remove your ID,
and declare deepLink
in here with a URI
that can host the
parameter for user ID,
so you can jump directly
into the user fragment
and can start chatting with
your friends right away.
So you no longer have
to hold onto IDs.
You no longer-- in
the modularized app--
would have to have
them in a shared space.
Instead of that,
you have your URIs
that you can share
across the application.
And within a friend list
fragment, what we then would do
is we simply build up
the URI and navigate
to our destination.
Another problem
that we came across
is when you navigate--
not within an app that
has library modules, but
one that has dynamic feature
modules.
The question around here is,
where are we going with this?
As you can see,
dynamic feature modules
have a bit of a different
way that the dependencies
are on one another.
They can depend on the app.
It's really tricky to navigate
between those features
when it comes to
modules that are not
on device in particular.
Dynamic feature modules
can be installed initially,
or can be downloaded later on.
We've heard questions around
this over the past year,
and we thought about
it, and we have
started to work on a new
library that is extending
the navigation library.
That will allow you to
intercept navigating
to separate destinations.
Then, if the module that we're
looking for is not installed,
it will take care of all
the downloading for that,
provides you with a
couple of callbacks
to either provide your own
UI while it's downloading,
or with a default safe version
for you to use as well.
And then once the module
is downloaded and ready,
it will continue navigating.
If the modules installed
initially, all what it does
is it directs you directly
to your target destination.
We just looked in a bit
of the future what's
in store for navigation.
And to talk a little bit more
about the bigger picture here,
let me invite back Ian.
[APPLAUSE]
IAN LAKE: Thanks, Ben.
I'm really excited about the
dynamic feature navigation,
and looking forward to
seeing that later this year.
But I wanted to talk
a little bit more
generally about just where
we're going with navigation.
I realized it took us a while to
get to that 1.0 stable release,
but from now on
what we're trying
to move towards is a much
faster iteration time.
So the time between the first
alpha and the first release,
to beta, to RC, to stable.
We realized that not
everyone is happy
using the latest alpha release.
Sometimes, a little
bit of that stability--
or at least the word, stable,
or the lack of the word, alpha--
can really help
win over PMs, who
aren't as familiar with what
alpha means for navigation.
We're really trying to focus on
just a small set of features.
What we talked about
today were the core
of the features
in navigation 2.1.
At this point we're saying,
no, let's cut it off here,
and let's go towards
beta and RC and stable
now, rather than
continuing to add features
over and over again.
But that doesn't mean that we're
not working on more things.
There's certainly a lot
more-- the dynamic feature
navigator is one thing.
But we're also really
looking at your feedback.
We have, and we use, the
issuetracker.google.com
extensively, particularly
for navigation.
And all these counts here are
actually the number of stars
that you all have given
for navigation features.
We can see, we've
done pretty good.
We fixed a fair few of them.
Some of these are actually
fixed in navigation 2.1,
based on your feedback.
But there's still
a few more to do.
And if it's not in 2.1, it's
going to be in 2.2, or 2.3
as we go through things.
We realize some
of these things--
like multiple backstacks--
are very highly requested.
And they do mean that
we also need to work
on the underlying library.
So for example, that one--
we should probably get
that working in fragments,
and then working in
navigation, as well.
That's certainly bigger efforts.
But it's something that
we're dedicated to do,
and something that
we think that would
be great to have out to all
of you in the near future.
I'd really like to continue.
If you have more
feature requests,
bug reports, anything,
please let us know.
If we can find an
issue for it already,
we're certainly happy
to look at that.
But your stars really do drive
the future of navigation.
[MUSIC PLAYING]